well and one of the things that are just
I can't wait for your next book I mean
ripped two bestsellers already crush it
and thank you economy can't wait for Jab
Jab Jab right hook depends on and you
know as I watch your videos and I see
the bits of pieces that you're you know
putting out there right now one of the
things that is so compelling is how
you're teaching people to not only tell
stories but you're teaching people how
to tell stories through social so it's
sharing not pushing so why why do you
think that that is so important that
people understand there's not pushing is
about telling stories they're so cool
because
let's go top-line it's really important
number one because the attention of the
consumer is there you know this great
guy right here this this San Diego
resident that does not like the Chargers
he exactly him fifteen years ago would
have watched a lot of television and
read the newspaper and his attention is
now in his phone and other places and
every business in the world's only job
is to tell people their story somewhere
along the decision-making path as we
started going to desktop computers SEO
and SEM mattered
banners mattered pre-rolls mattered as
we go to mobile new dynamics tough do
those banner ads on a mobile device like
that the game changes social networks
are very fertile grounds to do marketing
and storytelling the problem is most
people disrespect them see what's
happened is every other platform pretty
social all of that was a place to
distribute your message social is living
and breathing a customer can have a
profile just like you can big company
and that dynamic changes a customer can
say something about your company and
lots of other customers can see it at
scale that changes the dynamic most of
all we're disrespecting the psychology
of why somebody's in a phone scrolling
through their newsfeed
and so what I'm trying to do is help
people understand that a three hour
movie needs different creative than a
30-second commercial which needs
different creative than a radio right
the radio ad is a great place to do a
jingle right you're not gonna get a
jingle on a billboard on a highway
understanding how to tell your story
within Facebook Twitter Tumblr Pinterest
Instagram vine snapchat is very
important because they have hundreds of
millions of users tens of millions on
the lower scale but they're all very
different but everybody was watching
this video buckets in this social media
and the way they really evolved into is
just using it to distribute other
information they go to their Facebook
wall their company page they put three
words and they put a link to something
else and they think of social as
distribution not as a place to natively
tell a story that's where I think the
opportunity lies in the next half decade
so what do you would you tell the
company